Let's go back to the main project view.
Once you've created the necessary
services and activities,
you need to register them in the Android
Manifest XML so that Android-ware on
the phone and wearable side knows that
you have watch faces to select from.
Let's have a look at the wearable
Android XML file first.
Firstly, you need to request
PROVIDE_BACKGROUND and
WAKE_LOCK permissions.
You need to do this on the phone side
as well since the phone app must always
request every permission
needed by the wearable.
Let's now look at the service
definitions in the manifest.
You can see that each watch face
has a unique service entry.
Let's look at the definition
of DIgitalWatchFaceService.
You'll notice we've
declared our service,
given it a human readable name And
specify BIND_WALLPAPER for permissions.
The first item we have inside here
is android.service.wallpaper.
This needs to refer to
a watch_face.xml file.
And when we look at the declaration,
it looks like this.
You can see here, there's
a wallpaper element declared here.
Next we have the preview and
preview circular attributes.
These are used to define images
that will be shown as previews on
the companion or
watch when selecting a watch face.
You can see that if we right-click and
go to the declaration,
this is what it looks like.
You can specify a separate image for
round displays if you
have a different layout.
And if you don't provide one,
it'll fall back to the square one.
You can create these images by just
taking a screenshot of your watch face
running on a device or emulator.
We also have
a companionConfigurationAction,
which specifies if we'll be providing
an activity on the phone companion side
to configure the watch face.
This enables the little gear
icon on the phone side.
That we tried earlier.
We create a unique name here
with our own package name and
tag it CONFIG_DIGITAL.
We also have
a wearableConfigurationAction
which specifies we'll be
providing an activity to run on the
wearable to configure the watch face.
This enables the little gear icon on
the wearable side to make changes.
We use the same unique name as the phone
companion configuration action earlier.
We also declare an intent filter for
a wallpaper service with
a category of watch face.
Like here to complete
the definition of our service.
Finally, we need to declare our
DigitalWatchFaceWearableConfigActivity
which is the activity we'll run if the
user wants to configure this watch face.
We need to add an intent filter that
includes the default and wearable
configuration categories for the watch
face picket to see this activity.